speaking of musical talent good singers
and musicians always impress me alright
but you know it also blows me away it's
the things I can't do and we have a
talented beat boxer alright it's a skill
he's here it's a skill that I don't have
but I can definitely appreciate and I
try and do when no one's around
alright drunk everything's good there's
a beatbox they're blowing up on social
media right now he's so good Will Smith
has become a fan take a look at the
video that started it all well that'd be
boxers name is verbal ace and he's here
today y'all stand up
[Applause]
first of all I have a question like as a
vocalist does that hurt it used to oh
you just trained it for that I'm like
all that like breathing in and out whoa
yeah that's got to be rough on the
chords yes the first thing I actually
had to learn how to do is breathe good
used to like just do it until I run out
of breath God even that was cool
and that was so simple for you but I'm
blown away oh my gosh okay so you got to
beatbox with Will Smith like how did
that happen uh it all started when I was
a kid I would try to make sounds the
same sounds I hear in video games you
know play video game came over and put
stuff out on social media I have like
over two hundred and fifty million views
[Applause]
this all started with Will Smith's post
one of the the airport clip on the his
social media and then he posted another
video the same day saying he was
obsessed and I actually had an
opportunity to surprise him on a TV show
in London and I didn't think he was
gonna be there cuz it's Will Smith come
on when I finally walked out on stage
and I beatboxed he screamed when he saw
me and I had I had to stay I had to keep
performing because it's the first time I
met her in person so in my head I was
still doing it but you know on camera I
was like yeah you know it all felt like
a dream come true like I still couldn't
believe it happened let's see what you
got Horne ventriloquist
[Music]
[Applause]
I just I just firmly I just gave away my
secret me time I get lost in a song I'd
do the Invo you're awesome and you're
fantastic I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this